- When I'm lugging all my
makeup across the country
or I'm having to spend an
extra 30 minutes to get
ready for something and
my friend Andrew's just
sitting on the couch
- Right.
- Just twiddling his thumbs,
while I'm having to put on
eyeliner in my water line,
which means you're
poking in your eye.
And yeah, I don't have to do it,
but it makes my eye
look that much better.
- Yeah.
- It's exhausting, Gaby.
- To be fair, my
girlfriend doesn't do it.
- Your girlfriend doesn't do?
- No makeup, nothing.
- Well, she's also gay.
- Yeah, well, so am I!
(rock music)
- Gaby Dunn is our
guest right now.
Gaby Dunn is a author, comedian,
do you still do stand-up?
- No, I mean, I did
storytelling on our book tour.
- Okay, so yeah.
- But yeah.
- But just a funny, cool chick.
Gaby Dunn, her book "Bad With
Money: the imperfect art of
getting your financial
shit together"
is available online now.
You have a book,
you wrote a book.
- This is like a
nonfiction that is based on
the podcast "Bad With
Money" that is about,
I don't know the genre
financial memoir is a thing now,
but it's like a
financial memoir.
But also like a
help, helpful book.
- Okay, what.
You have a podcast
called "Bad With Money"?
- Yes.
- In which you talk to
comedians and funny, cool people
about
- Well,
- Being bad with money.
Tell me about the podcast.
- For season one, so I didn't
know anything about money.
I would cry about it all
the time, I was like.
- I find I'm avoiding the issue.
I don't even want to
talk to you about money.
That's why you're
here to talk about it.
- No, I know.
- That's how much people
don't wanna talk about money.
- Yes.
I think I've had
some people be like,
"I love you so much,
"I can't listen because
it gives me anxiety."
- Yeah.
- So I get it.
- Yes.
- But I started not knowing
anything and I would cry.
That was like, my big thing
that I would cry about.
And I just was always
in the hole somehow
and like, always had debt
and never talked
to anyone about it.
And never, like it was
like my secret shame.
And then, I had the
opportunity to do a podcast
and they were like,
"Well, do you wanna do
something about LBGTQ issues?
"Do you wanna do something
about sex positivity?"
And I was like,
"Actually, the thing that I
cry about everyday is money.
"Maybe we should
just expose that."
- So the first,
- Run towards it.
- I know.
- Yeah.
- So the first season,
which is super healthy.
- I think so.
- The first season.
- The thing you're most
scared to talk about,
why don't they start
a show about it.
- Yes.
- I mean, that's nuts.
Well, good for you.
Okay, so the first season.
- Was me mostly talking to
comedians and other artists
and just sort of being like,
"How do you make money?
"Like, how do you do this,
like what's going on?"
- Yeah.
- "What's your situation?"
And I, you know, moving
to LA from New York,
I didn't realize, oh everyone,
some people have
their parents' money,
or some people have side
jobs that I don't know about
or whatever.
So I would compare myself
so much to other people
without knowing that they,
their situations were
so different from mine.
- Yeah, yep.
- So I would, like, you know,
we would have the same income.
But I take care of
some family members
and I had student
loans and whatever.
And then I would compare
myself to people who would,
who didn't have
any student loans
or were getting money
from their parents.
- Yes.
- And I was like, "But
we have the same income!
"So how am I struggling?"
And then I was like,
"Oh, other people have
totally different situations."
- And was that the
first step in kind of,
is that the first step in
- Transparency.
- But that's so hard, 'cause
no one talks about money.
- I know.
- I grew up in a house
where it was like,
"Nikki, you don't tell your
friends how much your dad makes.
"You're not even."
I wasn't even allowed to know
how much money my dad made.
- Right.
- And it wasn't like a ton
of money or it wasn't even.
Or when it wasn't
a ton of money,
I wasn't allowed
to know either way.
Why?
- But in the book I talk
about I got such whiplash,
because my parents would go
through phases where they would
have some money and then
they would have nothing.
- Yes, me too!
- And so, there would be
days where they'd be like,
"Oh, yeah, you could
definitely go with your friends
"to this whatever.
"You could go to the
dance with your friends
"and get a new dress."
And then like, two days
later, they'd be like,
"No, you can't."
- I learned the word
destitute really early on.
- Yeah.
- My dad would always
say, "We're destitute."
And I was like, "I
don't know what that."
And I had to look it up and
I'm like, "Oh no, we're poor."
Like, I felt the same
back and forth of
do we have all
the money or none?
- None of the money.
And then I would get stressed
out, which is parentalizing,
where I would be be 12 and
my parents would spend money
and I'd go, "Should
we be doing this?"
- Yes!
Oh my god, I remember the day.
I remember the day
I, we were driving.
We were moving from Cincinnati
to St. Louis, I was six.
And I remember being in the car
and seeing the St. Louise Arch
and just having a realization,
I don't know what conversation
was happening
between my parents,
but I remember being
like, "We're poor."
- [Gaby] Yes.
- Like, we're poor
and I am the only one
that's gonna make it
so that my sister doesn't
spend my parents money.
- [Gaby] Yes!
- 'Cause they're
not gonna tell her.
So I started,
- Yes!
- Being like, "Lauren,
you can't get."
I would like,
- Exactly the same.
- take her inside
at 7/11 and be like,
"You can only get
one candy, Lauren."
- Exactly the same.
- 'Cause I was protecting
her from my parents having
to tell her.
- Yes.
- And just protecting my
parents from not being broke
and fighting about it
- Yes.
- And being scared.
- Almost exactly the same.
I have a little sister too.
- [Nikki] Yes.
- And she, I interview her
in the book and she's like,
"I had no concept.
"I thought we were fine.
She was like, "If I ask
Mom and Dad for something
"and they said yes, I would
go great, we have the money."
So I started being
like, telling her same.
I started telling her, "You
can't ask, you have to stop."
- Yes!
- And then she got a lot of
stuff that I didn't get because
- Same.
- I was like, "Well, if she's."
In my mind, because my
older brother also was like,
having trouble finding
a job at the time,
so they were helping him.
And so I became like, okay,
I should be successful on my own
because they're already
helping two of their kids.
So I need to be the one
that they don't help.
- Yes.
- Which is so stressful
to put on a teenager.
- Yep.
I would always be
the one to take cuts.
- Yes!
- Because I wanted,
I didn't want them to
know that I knew either.
- [Gaby] Yes!
- Like, I was trying to protect
them from being embarrassed.
- I would go, "It's
fine, I don't need it."
- Exactly, I don't need it.
- Ugh!
- And then, but I
really wanted it.
- Yes.
- And I wanted all the things
that my friends were getting.
And you're right,
the transparency.
I didn't understand, how
does my friend afford
Abercrombie & Fitch when her
dad has a similar job to my.
Like, I just didn't
understand it.
The transparency thing
is so huge in comedy
because I think that,
especially for women,
we get paid less than
men a lot of times.
And, as comedians,
we're all so private
about what we're making,
and I'm like, "No, it
shouldn't be private.
"We should all talk about it
"because we should all be
getting paid the same and more."
- Yeah.
- And I think that when you do
find out what someone makes,
you realize, "Oh, I need
to be asking for more.
"I deserve more."
- I had an interesting
experience where I was,
me and this girl were both
speaking at a conference.
She dm'ed me to be like, "Hey,
what are they paying you?"
And I was like, "Oh,
that's a great question."
So I told her and she was like,
"Okay, wow, they're
paying me half of that."
So I said, "Oh, go to then
right now, drop my name."
- [Nikki] Yep.
- "Say 'Gaby told me she's
getting this and I want this'."
- Yeah.
- And then they did,
they upped her fee.
- That's great.
- And I was like,
absolutely, for sure.
Like, everyone
should be doing that.
- But people get so
uncomfortable when, you know,
when they're asked about
how much money they make,
both when they're
not making enough
and when they're
making too much.
When you're making a lot of
money, I wanna know every cent.
That's why I always loved
being friends with Amy Schumer
because I realized, 'cause
she was transparent about it.
She wasn't bragging,
she was just like,
"Can you believe
the amount of money
"I'm about to get
for this thing?"
And she would tell me, and
so now I know I have these,
I know what I should be
making at different levels,
- Yes.
- Because I saw her rise
right where I kind of am,
and so I know what to expect.
And I was appreciative
of her telling me that.
I never took it as brag, even
though some people could have.
But I felt like it was,
it made me excited.
- It let you know
your self-worth.
Like, it let you know
what you should ask for.
- Yes, it really did.
But I still struggle.
I'm at a point now
where I feel rich.
I feel like I don't want
for anything and I'm great.
But there are days
when I'm like,
I stress about money.
I'll still find ways
to stress about money.
I think it's something I
go to much like my weight,
or my hair, or my skin.
Where you're just stressing
about something else,
and you need to find
a place to put it.
And so you put it in your money.
- There's a huge difference
between broke and poor.
And I think I'm
still pretty broke.
- Yeah.
- Like, I think I have
problems with overspending
or I immediately.
My sister had a thing
where she was like,
"I went to the
dentist and my tooth."
Her tooth fell out.
And she's unemployed.
And so it was gonna cost her,
like a thousand dollars
to get a new tooth.
And I was like,
"Well, you can't be walking
around without a tooth."
So I was like, she was
upset and I was like,
"I'll cover it."
- Yeah.
- Just stuff like that
where I still do it.
And I have a friend who's
an actress who was like,
"You gotta stop that right now."
'Cause now she knows that she
can just ask you for money.
But I'm not gonna let her
walk around without a tooth.
- I feel the same way.
I only wanna make more
money because I wanna pay
for people to get teeth.
- Yeah, exactly!
- That can't afford teeth.
I really do.
I hate the idea
of these expenses
that come up in people's lives.
Like, I've lent.
Last year I got, my
money guy called me,
and every year I dread the call
of what my spending
was the year.
- Yeah.
- 'Cause I don't
look at my budgeting,
I don't look at what
I spent on what,
and I kind of just
know that he sees it
and is gonna judge me.
And he's like,
"The biggest things you spend
money on are lending people,
"giving away money."
- Yep.
- And I'm glad, I was
glad to hear that,
'cause I never lent
money and regret.
I haven't lent money
yet and regretting it.
I've chosen good
people to do it for.
But, it does feel like.
I get something more
out of it sometimes
than I think the person does.
- Well, what sucks too is
that there's so many medical
Go-Fund-Mes, and you just
get them all the time.
- Yeah, that's another thing.
- And then.
- Go-Fund-Mes, I throw
so much money at those.
- I do too.
And then they're not,
they're considered
personal gifts,
they're not
considered donations,
so you can't write
them off on your taxes.
- What?
Really?
- Yes, it's horrible.
- That's ridiculous.
- Yes.
So you can't write
them off on your.
There was an article I just read
that was this girl go some
money for her cancer treatments
and then her taxes ended
up being $19000 on it.
- Oh my god.
- Right, right.
- So she needs a
Go-Fund-Me for her taxes.
- For her taxes!
I mean, it's not set up.
Our country's not set up well.
I don't know if
anyone knows that.
- The like, real like it.
(rock music)